23 years ago former Ravens GM Ozzie
Newsome drafted not one but two Hall of
Famers in the first round of the 1996
draft the first Baltimore Ravens draft
ever Newsome if he didn't already have a
bronze bust for his time as a player
with the Browns great tight end in his
era would have a bronze bust for his
time as a general manager his
contributions to the game so the NBA
Draft is tonight we borrow from the NBA
draft for our PFT live draft and today's
topic the best all-time NFL draft errs
the individuals who are the best
all-time at drafting talent in the NFL
Chris Sims go ahead and draft tales or
heads read coin toss you'll get the
first pick although this is one of those
days where there isn't an obvious one
maybe there isn't an option and the coin
is in the air Wow there really isn't an
obvious one here there are a lot of
different ways we can go but you know
we've spent a lot of time today talking
about the greatest player of all time in
NFL history at least the greatest
quarterback possibly the greatest player
at any position and he was found at pick
number 199 round six in the early days
of Bill Belichick's tenure with the New
England Patriots and even though there's
been some misses all in all they have
found a way to identify players who end
up being good they love football they
have that psychology where they take
less money for the most part than other
players would take they have built that
team from a draft that has brought in
both star players and role players and
everything in between Bill Belichick how
can you not make Bill Belichick one of
the best drafters of all time when they
he has put together the best program of
all time over the last 19 years in New
England and the way they've run the
draft is a huge part of the reason why
the Patriots have been so good no doubt
Mike I mean he's on my list to here I
mean I'm trying to win the draft so I'm
gonna point out some negatives all right
I mean I mean you're right
Bill Belichick oddly enough I would say
this is like maybe some of his
weaknesses to what he is
as a GM / head coach but yet his
weakness is still a lot better than the
people who have it as a strength you
know he's miss stunts like some high-end
people right but I think we're you know
what you're trying to kind of talk about
and I'll back you up with this it's okay
yeah maybe there's been some 1st and 2nd
and 3rd round picks that haven't worked
out but damn someone he's got you know
3rd and 4th and 5th and 6th and 7th
rounders who have worked out so many
times to help build their teams like
you're saying and the construction of
them to where injuries don't hurt and
the manipulating of the draft and if he
doesn't see the right value to trade
down and accumulate more picks I mean
yeah I don't know if I'd necessarily
hold him in the highest regard as the
best it's the best manipular the draft
I've ever seen for sure he has five
Super Bowl MVPs that come from guys take
in round six or later yeah right four of
them are Brady M ones Julian Edelman who
was a seventh round pick but yeah he he
knows how to find talent and you can't
have the best football program that the
NFL has ever seen without being somebody
who knows how to draft and he knows how
to draft I think because he's such a
great coach it overshadows his draft
prowess it's okay my case for Belichick
ball to even further
I mean undrafted free agents is where he
struck gold - I know that's maybe
outside the realm of this but I mean
he's been amazing with getting those
like free agent guys - so I'm not mad at
you their minds gonna beat that though
in Chuck Noll with the Pittsburgh
Steelers that's who I'm gonna lose why
make your case and I'll tell you why
you're wrong well I mean what do you
want to talk about Terry Brown jokes you
know
you know from Franco Harris Mike Webster
Lynn Swann John John Stallworth Jack
Lambert
I mean Mel Blount you just go on and on
and on but you know anything you read
about the history of the the Pittsburgh
Steelers and what they did I mean he set
them up for that dynasty it was his
vision his ability to pick talent and
late-round talent with certain guys who
weren't necessarily viewed as like you
know these big-time stars so yeah I'm
gonna put him up there I mean there's
four Super Bowls in that era in the
1970s that was on
heard of at the time and it was a
balanced football team on both sides I
mean they won the first two Super Bowls
kind of a defense and then the second
two Super Bowls they won with Terry
Bradshaw Aaron and out and throwing
bombs the stallworth and slaw Swan and
things like that too so yes I'm gonna
put Chuck Noll up there towards the top
of the list as far as the greatest
drafters ever here's where I am not
entirely sure why on whether or not
here's why yeah because we still don't
know who made those picks Dan Rooney was
the GM of those teams not Chuck Noll yes
and and and and Bill Belichick clearly
was in charge of the New England
Patriots and has been I mean I had Dan
Rooney not Chuck Noll on my list cuz he
was the GM of that team of those teams
in the 70s in the 1974 draft the best
ever
I just don't think Noll is the right guy
now that may win you some support when
we put this thing on social media and
let people vote on it because I
understand what you're coming from
you're coming from that Steelers dynasty
all together but Dan Rooney was the GM
of those teams not Chuck well I I
understand but any story I've ever read
or heard it's Chuck Noll working out
these guys oh I found this guy there I
found this guy there and I liked him and
whatever so I don't I didn't even know
Rooney had the GM role but whatever he's
the owner okay and I've always been led
to believe with anything I've read and
you know I'm a football historian that
Chuck Noll had to say of sorry we want
to pick this guy now Dan Rooney of
course was the owner and could say no
but to me it's always read like and my
understanding just talking to people
that Chuck Noll ultimately was the guy
that was putting that team together so I
disagree with you there
screw you and go to your second round
pick please here's what's amazing to me
the idea that Chuck Noll was as
successful as he was and he retired at
the age of 59 and his name never emerged
for a GM job a VP of football operations
a coaching job somewhere else I mean
that's amazing to me that given what he
did with the Steelers what in whatever
capacity it never got him any discussion
from anyone why wouldn't people be
clamoring to hire Chuck Noll in the in
the mid-90s given everything that he did
in the 70s and the teams that he put
together all right next pick for me I
got to go with
you know if we're going to talk about
dynasties and a guy who was the general
manager for the birth of a dynasty in
San Francisco Bill Walsh coach and GM of
the San Francisco 49ers putting together
that team that began with Joe Montana as
a third-round pick in 79 and build it
into a team that won plenty of Super
Bowls in the 80s a standard-bearer you
know there's that - every - every
decades got its team and it was the
49ers in the 80s and it was Bill Walsh
his genius that put together that team
so that one's a fairly easy one for me
bill transforming a horrible franchise
into a great franchise was Bill wall
yeah I'm not gonna you know how much did
Carmen policy have in there just to
throw a curveball out to you like you
did yeah of course I am I'm stealing at
Council I'm stealing your tricks okay
yeah but I'm with you I mean Bill Walsh
is the guy and I think he was of course
the guy making a lot of the picks but
whether it's Jerry Rice or Joe Montana
and the third round I mean you know
again I think one of the things that
goes overlooked with some of those 49er
teams in the 80s - that bill wash
doesn't get credit for because we talk
about offense and John Taylor and Roger
Craig and all the time we talk about
them those defenses were some of the
best in football you know they were
number one number two I know my dad
certainly had a deal with the 49ers and
that's the one thing he always talks
about is nobody gives those defenses
credit they were tough you know they
don't think they were the 85 Bears or
maybe they're the 91 Eagles but they
certainly were a formidable foe and that
was because of Bill Walsh and his
coaching so I'm I'm not mad at you there
either man this is Walsh was Walsh was
the GM from 79 to 82 he was the coach
from 79 to 88 but he was the GM for the
first four years and that's really where
they laid the foundation of those teams
yeah right okay so alright so this is
where it gets hard here I don't know
what to do okay I'm gonna go with Al
Davis okay
that's my next pick Wow yeah I'm going
to Dow you know just win baby okay I
mean up until the mid-2000s the Oakland
Raiders or the Oakland LA Oakland you
know Raiders whatever the hell you want
to call them alright they were up
towards the top winning percentage and
the history of all sports
any team sport combined they were up
there with us from from the times Al
Davis took over in the 60s they were
relevant all the way up until the mid
2000s they were always in a pile off
conversation a team that could make it
to the Super Bowl
but when you talk about the team in the
70s of course you know wins one Super
Bowl you know they had Kenny Stabler and
you know Caspar and so many good players
on both sides of the football
you know branch at receiver Biletnikoff
and then it went into the 80s and it was
Marcus Allen okay and oh they they bat
drafted bo Jackson and figured out who
hill might come and play for us they did
things like that you got into the 90s
and the they weren't always great but
you know he found a guy like Jon Gruden
and then they drafted some guys there
and built a team as well so I'm gonna
throw a leavis in there he's one of the
all-time great football minds and to me
one of the best draft pick and talent
evaluators ever yeah I agree with you
there it's just what happened after the
2002 Superbowl the disintegration of the
franchise during the final nine years of
his time running and even though he
wasn't the GM actively he did the
longevity I think had a lot to do with
it and the team yeah was so good back in
the 70s they they were always that team
that was right on the brink of winning a
Super Bowl before they finally did to
cap the 76 season all right you've left
one for me that is very obvious you know
people think it's a fairly recent
development in football that coaches end
up for niggling GM powers as well Vince
Lombardi when he arrived in Green Bay
was the coach and the general manager
and he put together the team of the 60s
the dominant force back when there was
no free agency you the only way you were
getting your players was through the
draft and I think they had 72 rounds of
the draft back in those days so it's not
like there was much in the way of
undrafted free agency you had to be able
to pick and pick and pick and pick and
he put together that team that won five
NFL championships and the first two
Super Bowls so this one's easy i
sandbagged you on that one baby vince
lombardi maybe should have been the
first overall pick it's pretty good I'm
not gonna deny any of that I mean yeah
he's Vince Lombardi and there's a reason
the Super Bowl trophy is named after him
and honestly I'm not gonna lie didn't
really even think of him that's a shame
on me
and now don't even have an argument to
look back to see if who he drafted and
who he didn't do to crap on your theory
they're so good pick by you okay good
pick I try to be this is yeah I don't
know where to go I'm in since you're
done I'm gonna throw the the names out
there that I Bill Parcells I he's in my
mind here okay Jimmy Johnson what he did
with that Cowboys team I mean that was
unbelievable three-year haul and the
draft where he just went wow I mean that
might have been the best three years
ever I'm torn between that I'm telling
you Ozzie Newsome and John Schneider
with the Seattle Seahawks I think it's
in this conversation - I think he's that
special of a picker but I'm gonna go
with Ozzie Newsome I am I think
ultimately and I like I mean I love
Jimmie Johnson and what he did but I
think just the longevity of what I see
Newsome did and building these teams
that were so competitive so physical
tough finding those right guys that fit
the theme in the mantra of how the
Baltimore Ravens wanted to play for
basically over 20 years straight and
there's only a few years here and there
where the team wasn't any good and I
don't know if I can necessarily say it
was ever Ozzie Newsome spa there were
some years where I think the coaching
was you know below average or they got a
little unlucky with injuries but man
it's one of the greatest GM's of all
time you know whether you want to talk
about Ray Lewis and some of the great
defensive players he's drafted the big
offensive linemen I mean he's had it all
and they were one of the best franchises
of the last 20 years because of him and
how he set them up
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports